centre géant ouvriront progressivement
leurs portes partout sur le territoire
le stade de france entré dans la danse
dès aujourd'hui mais quid des doses en
nombre suffisant des candidats au vaccin
ou de la logistique
alors les vaccinodromes véritable coup
d'accélérateur ou coup de communication
ce sera l'objet de notre décryptage ce
soir
l'ukraine appelle l'otan accélérer son
adhésion pour envoyer je suis un signal
à la russie moscou estime que cela ne
ferait qu'empirer la situation
kiev s'inquiète des mouvements de
troupes russes à la frontière la
situation dans le donbass au coeur un
échange hier entre diplomates russes et
américains l'union européenne inquiète
sur la situation des droits humains en
turquie
ursula von der leyen et charles michel
ont rencontré aujourd'hui recep tayyip
erdogan à ankara rencontre sous le signe
de l'apaisement les présidents du
conseil et de la commission réaffirmé
que la turquie demeurer un partenaire
important de lieux et souligné son rôle
dans l'accueil de réfugiés notamment
syrien
[Musique]
terminée la tolérance du week-end de
pâques la france métropolitaine est donc
entrée dans son troisième confinement
pour une durée de quatre semaines
écoles collèges et lycées ont eu renouer
avec l'enseignement à distance avant les
vacances de printemps parallèlement aux
mesures de restriction le gouvernement
compte sur la vaccination pour endiguer
l'épidémie
la cadence est supposé s'accélérer avec
l'ouverture aux quatre coins du pays de
vaccinodromes dont le stade de france
aujourd'hui
l'armée est également mise à
contribution puisque sept hôpitaux
militaires avons installé des centres
pour administrer jusqu'à mille doses par
jour
vacciner à tour de bras donc dans des
espaces géants un dispositif qui n'a pas
toujours eu les faveurs du gouvernement
tom abonnés c'est un néologisme inventé
au 21ème siècle qui fait couler beaucoup
d'encre le vaccinodromes une
infrastructure pouvant être assimilé à
un méga centres de vaccination certains
stades ont notamment été choisi pour
être transformés en vaccinodromes comme
ici à lyon
des initiatives saluées par le ministre
de la santé le service de santé des
armées va travailler à développer un
certain nombre de grands centres de
vaccination pour les appeler
vaccinodromes ou méga centre quel que
soit le quel que soit le nom il ya au
moins 35 centres qui vont être déployés
à la fois par l'armée les pompiers sur
le territoire national et nous déployons
avec l'état l'assurance maladie un
certain nombre d'autres aussi pour
pouvoir être capable justement
d'utiliser tous les vaccins qui nous
sont livrés et c'est aujourd'hui le
gouvernement embrassent cette stratégie
cela n'a pas toujours été le cas
revenons au mois de décembre 2020 alors
que certains de nos voisins comme
l'allemagne lance des vaccinodromes la
france se montre réticente et ce en
dépit des appels d'un certain nombre
d'élus locaux
voici ce qu'en disait le ministre de la
santé lors d'un discours devant les
sénateurs et par ailleurs lorsque nous
vaccinerons population générale certains
élus auront peut-être à coeur de mettre
à disposition des locaux non pas des
immenses vaccinodromes je n'y crois pas
une ferme opposition qui résonne
étrangement à nos oreilles aujourd'hui
alors même que les initiatives de ce
genre se multiplient désormais pourtant
c'est avec aplomb que le même olivier
ferrand déclaré
à la fin du mois de mars ensuite faut
poser la question des vaccinodromes ya
jamais eu de religion antiga qui
donneront donc si on résume on est passé
d'un non catégorique à la mise en place
d'au moins 40 méga centres de
vaccination juste en l'espace de trois
mois
c'est donc ce qu'on peut appeler un
revirement certains élus auront
peut-être à coeur de mettre à
disposition des locaux non pas des
immenses vaccinodromes je n'y crois pas
il n'y a jamais eu de religion anti
vaccinaux drôme les arguments du
ministre de la santé sur la stratégie
locale déployés au début de campagne
peuvent s'entendre
en revanche comment expliquer que l'on
mise aujourd'hui sur ce qu'on dénigre
est fière sans doute les injonctions du
président de la république ont-elles
pesé sur les préférences de l'ailé
verrons d'ici à la fin de l'été tous les
français de plus de 18 ans qui le
souhaitent pourront être vaccinés
reste maintenant à juger de l'efficacité
de ces vaccinodromes en termes de
communication rien ne serait pire que
d'avoir changé de braquet pour un
résultat médiocre
c'est pourtant ce que redoutent certains
comme raquel garrido en scène porte
parole de la france insoumise elle
s'inquiète notamment de la
transformation du stade de france en
vaccinodromes ouvert à toute la
population francilienne avec un objectif
de 2000 vaccinations par jour il y aura
un effet aspirateur à vaccins au
détriment des populations fragiles âgées
et isolées du département si cet effet
aspirateur reste à prouver le touch en
tout cas au fond du problème
le gouvernement aura beau ouvrir autant
de vaccinodromes qu'il le souhaite
encore faut-il que des doses de vaccin
soit accessible en nombre suffisant
alors les vaccinodromes plus tôt
laissant de vaccination géant un
véritable coup d'accélérateur ou un coup
de communication place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités pour en
parler
avec nous pierre hurmic maire europe
ecologie les verts de bordeaux philippe
gonzalez maire de lubersac en corrèze
enfin karim khelfaoui médecins
généralistes bonsoir messieurs bonsoir à
tous les trois et merci d'être en direct
sur rt france le stade de france qui
s'est donc transformée aujourd'hui en
vaccinodromes géant
c'est la nouvelle arme du gouvernement
pour accélérer la campagne de
vaccination 46 vaccinodromes devrait
voir le jour dans le pays au mois
d'avril regarder cette carte pour vous
donner une idée à bordeaux d'ailleurs un
pierre remy cas vous allez en avoir un
vous n'êtes avoir la chance d'en avoir
on ne sait pas encore si c'est vraiment
une chance on va essayer de décrypter ça
ensemble ce sont en tout cas sont
présentés ainsi un par le gouvernement
comme une preuve d'une accélération de
la campagne pour autant est-ce vraiment
le cas selon vous monsieur le maire on
dirait surtout l'usagé points surtout il
faut éviter d'avoir des paroles de rap
tour comme chaque été c'est qu'on était
celle du ministre on l'a vu dans votre
reportage n'a pas de religion en la
matière je pense qu'il faut privilégier
c'est le pragmatisme ou sa manche ou si
sa mort où ça marche pas et ça marche
pas si les doses de vaccin sont au
rendez vous on met en place deux des
lieux de vaccination massive ont
confortés qu'ils soient à la hauteur de
l'approvisionnement en vaccins a même si
une deuxième condition que nous avons
posées sur la table dès le début c'est
qu'il ne faut pas que ça se fasse au
détriment des centres de proximité
il faut vacciner tous azimuts et tous
azimuts ça veut dire ne pas privilégier
une solution technique au détriment
d'une autre
il faut des maximes drôme parce que il
faut maintenant faire du massif qu'on a
produit jusqu'à présent mais il faut
aussi faire du sur mesure
c'est à dire conserver des centres de
profit de proximité en ville comme dans
l'est comme dans les zones rurales font
pas vacciner tout le monde dans
l'élection de rome ce n'est pas
forcément adapté à toutes les
populations et à tous les territoires
on va y revenir justement sur cette
notion proximité parce qu'il ya quelques
critiques qui se concentrent justement
sur ce thème
on va aller voir de plus près comment ça
s'est passé aujourd'hui au stade de
france première
tine est le plus grand au centre de
vaccination désormais dans le pays nos
équipes étaient sur place pour
recueillir le sentiment de ces
franciliens au moment de l'injection
regarder à l'intérieur s'est bien passé
et reçoit bien les gens ils s'occupent
bien mais bon les vaccins n'étaient pas
là il fallait qu'on attende
alors quand tu ça arrive et ça on
attendait vraiment un bon moment et puis
20 minutes une lumière et puis après des
vaccins il est arrivé ben c'est mal
organisé tout le monde pour nos roues
les blouses blanches tout ça tout le
monde tourne en rond mais c'est très mal
organisé
pascal entrées on devrait nous donner un
numéro est passé par numéro mais là les
derniers passés les premiers nous
l'atome l'organisation c'est un peu un
peu le fouillis mais sinon ça va on
attend un petit peu et après on est
enregistrée sur des ordinateurs
voilà avec la capitale et tout ça pour
la sécu et ensuite on attend et un
médecin ou une infirmière vient vous
chercher pour vous faire vacciner ont
manifestement c'était pas toujours la
fête notamment au niveau de
l'organisation ce matin premier jour on
le rappelle quand même docteur vous vous
avez un petit peu de repos recul sur le
bec cynodrome à marseille notamment au
vélodrome
comment ça se passe on s'organise plutôt
bien ça permet de vacciner plus vite
alors ça permet d'avoir une organisation
subtilement de masse mais c'est
intéressant pour certains vaccins
notamment je pense au freezer qui a des
conditions de nécessité de rester dans
une chaîne du froid qui font qu'une
campagne décentralisée de vaccination
est un peu difficile avec ce vaccin
mais quelque part en fait depuis le
début on fait dans des centres de
vaccination pour ce vaccin pour les
autres c'est un poumon
- forcément intéressant astrazeneca le
jeune sun and johnson qui ne nécessite
pas une chaîne du froid particulière
pourrait très bien faire l'objet d'une
campagne décentralisée est en réalité à
mon sens on est en train de la de
rentrer dans une nouvelle étape d'une
campagne de communication qui a commencé
maintenant il ya un mois et demi où il a
s'agit de dire qu'on avait accéléré
puisque ans passés d'une vaccination
chez les médecins à une vaccination
d'abord chez les pharmaciens puis
ensuite on nous a dit les vétérinaires
etc vont pouvoir vacciner maintenant
nouveautés vaccinodromes en réalité vous
avez très bien poser le problème le
problème ce n'est pas la manière dont on
va aller structures qu'on va faire pour
faire cette campagne de vaccination il
faut qu'ils ont des de tous types
mais c'est surtout est ce que on aura
assez de doses et c'est bien là que ça
pêche aujourd'hui on n'a absolument pas
plus de doses mais en tout cas ça arrive
un peu au fur et à mesure de ce que
veulent bien donner les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et ça c'est un vrai
problème politique
c'est un vrai projet politique en france
et c'est un vrai problème politique dans
le monde entier parce qu'en réalité si
on fait une campagne de vaccination qui
n'est pas globale on risque de se
retrouver demain avec des variantes qui
vont être sélectionnés parce que dans
certains pays on n'aura pas vacciner
aussi vite que en europe et que on va se
retrouver avec du coup des variants qui
vont résister au vaccin il va falloir
vacciner tout le monde donc aujourd'hui
on a ce problème là et il est urgent
pour répondre à cette urgence ce
problème là de lever les brevets sur les
vaccins c'est une possibilité que le
gouvernement a avec les licences
d'office pour lancer une campagne de
production de ces vaccins de masse et
qu'on ne soit pas obligé d'attendre que
des laboratoires privés veuille bien
nous fournir sauf que pour l'instant les
laboratoires ne sont pas vraiment
d'accord en tout cas c'est une grosse
machine qui concentrent beaucoup de
moyens au détriment de des centres de
vaccination on le rappelle 1700 dans
dans le pays je propose avant de
poursuivre ce débat de regarder
d'écouter ce tweet du député de la
france est soumise eric coquerel
l'ouverture du vaccinodromes du stade de
france peut être un soulagement
à condition que ça ne soit pas au
détriment des centres de proximité et
même qu on les renforce
chacun comprendra
que c'est parfois compliqué pour les
personnes âgées dice qu'au stade qui est
parfois loin de ça fait écho à ce que
nous disait un pierre hurmic tout à
l'heure et ça fait écho aussi à beaucoup
de critiques de la part des pharmaciens
et des maires ruraux qu'on a entendu ap
le gouvernement trouvait justement des
solutions de proximité est ce qu on a
fermé des centres de vaccination au
profit de vaccinodromes philippe
gonzalez vous qui être maire de lubersac
en corrèze oui effectivement il ya eu
une tentative dix ans de fermeture notre
de notre autres centres de vaccination
qui avait été mis en place depuis pas
mal de temps et qui assure et quand même
un autre échelle bien sûr une
vaccination adapté puisque bien sûr des
grands les grands centres sont utiles
dans les grandes concentrations de
populations dans les villes d'ailleurs
on peut constater qu'ils sont
essentiellement axées sur cette
population là alors que nous vous avez
montré une carte qui parle beaucoup
tout à l'heure c'est que on remarque un
énorme trou vide au niveau du centre de
la france là justement où nous nous
trouvons et donc depuis le début nous
sommes mis au service de notre
population pour mettre en place tout ce
qu'il faut pour que la vaccination soit
faite et et malheureusement le 1er avril
c'était pas un poisson nous annoncer que
ont fermé le centre
heureusement après après pas mal de deux
manifestations par les médias par
l'intermédiaire des médias par notre
facebook et l'intervention de notre
population à différents niveaux na
la préfecture a réagi de façon positive
et nous annoncer que notre centre ne
serait pas fermé parce qu il est bien
évident que pour nous dans nos zones
rurales nous ne pouvons pas nous occuper
d'une population éparpillés sur une
surface assez grande
et puis les a menés d'une manière ou
d'une autre sur un centre qui serait à
une cinquantaine de kilomètres avec des
personnes qui sont relativement âgés
avec des comorbidités et avec des
problèmes associés alors que nono
médecin sur place et nos personnels
soignants sont tout à fait en mesure
d'abord de connaître les gens qui sont
amenés à vacciner et nous avons
suffisamment de bénévoles dans nos
villages pour les convoquer nominalement
et les faire venir
100 kg et d'attentes sans qu'il y ait de
problème particulier avec aucun risque
pris donc tu crois que leur ne va pas
sans l'autre que l'on fasse des grands
centres de vaccination bien entendu si
logique si on veut être efficace sur une
population énorme puisque on vise l
intégralité de la population française
quand même mais surtout ne pas oublier
que dans nous donne à nous tout ce que
nous pouvons mettre en place sera utile
pour le pour la recherche d'une solution
nationale et que tous les maires mais
moi oui oui il ya beaucoup de critiques
de la part des médecins aussi à on
entendait karim khelfaoui oki qui
restait quand même
voilà mon modéré mais il y en a d'autres
qui sont vraiment en colère écouter e
jean paul hamon le président d'honneur
de la fédération de la fédération des
médecins de france dans l'aisne mes
copains médecins généralistes me disent
qu'ils sont obligés d'annuler le
rendez-vous de vaccin car les flacons
d'astra son parti dans les centres de
vaccination et qu'il faut faire des bons
de transport en ambulance pour que leurs
patients y aille
on vit une époque formidable c'est vrai
pierre hurmic beaucoup d'aberrations
dans cette campagne parfois des des
incohérences qu'on a du mal à expliquer
est-ce qu'on applique le bon mari
maillage territorial et la bonne
stratégie tout de même pour vacciner
massivement la population
je pense qu'il fait une politique
équilibrée et je suis assez sensible à
ce que dit mon collègue philippe
gonzalez
il a raison je veux pas perdre de vue
les zones rurales je pense en faire deux
maps à 38% de la population vit dans des
communes de moins de 3500 habitants donc
naturellement il faut faire du sur
mesure
dussault mesure dans les zones rurales
mais également dans les villes dans les
villes tout le monde ne peut pas aller
dans ces méga centres de vaccination
nous avons actuellement cinq centres de
proximité à bordeaux j'espère que nous
allons les conserver mais je
souhaiterais même canet davantage et
puis aussi un challenge qui concerne
autant les zones urbaines que les zones
rurales
c'est ce qu'on appelle la stratégie
duale et vert il ya des gens qui peuvent
pas se déplacer
il faut aller les voir nous ici au
niveau de la métropole bordelaise en a
pu négocier a besoin de transfusions
sanguines qui ne prêtent leur leur mega
bus qui sert habituellement don du sang
aux transfusions pour précisément aller
vers les populations qui ne peuvent pas
se déplacer et ouvert qui on ira pour
les vacciner levac site des vaccinés sur
place il n'y a pas une solution
il ya plusieurs solutions il faut faire
de la dentelle tout ça je disais n'ya
pas de religion il n'ya pas de religion
soyons pragmatiques faisant moins
d'antennes mais surtout nous donnons pas
l'impression pour vacciner mieux dans
les centres urbains que dans les zones
rurales
je pense qu'il faut là aussi un souci
d'équilibré surtout d'équité envers tous
les territoires rien aussi un problème
de confiance envers certains vaccins
notamment celui d'astrazeneca on répète
la france a trois avec sa disposition
pour vacciner pour l'instant au stade de
france par exemple aujourd'hui et d'un
et voulait tous d'une fadeur on s'est
aperçu à cette occasion d'ailleurs que
les doses de modern a été boudée comme
celle d'astrazeneca comment vous vous
l'expliquer karim khelfaoui je pense que
ça s'explique principalement par la
communication qui a eu autour de ces
vaccins
celle de faiseurs on en a pourquoi
entendu parler et plutôt en bien dans
les différents médias à sens unique a eu
des déboires puisqu'il a été un moment
suspendues et puis réintroduits donc
forcément ça n'aide pas la confiance
quand on sait que dès le départ avant
que ces vaccins arrivent y avait quand
même une forte défiance par rapport au
vaccin et une forte crainte vu la
vitesse à laquelle les avaient été
développées et qui se basent tous sur un
contre que ces trois là sur des
technologies relativement nouvelle
ensuite le modern abba lui il a fait à
mon avis l'objet d'un déficit de
publicité dans les médias et par le
gouvernement donc tout le moulin peu
oublié parce qu'en fait c'est un médecin
qui a été moins commandé que les autres
donc il ya moins de doses donc on en a
moins parlé mais en fait il est à peu
près comme faiseur à ceci près qu'il est
plus facile à conserver qui a pas besoin
d'une telle chaîne du froid par rapport
aux files heures il est un petit peu
moins contraignant mais voilà après
dupont se retrouve dans une situation où
on se retrouve avec des grands centres
qui du coup que me disait mon confrère
jean paul année on se retrouve à
déshabiller pierre pour habiller paul
elie vaccins qu'on pourrait faire de
manière beaucoup plus décentralisée avec
l'aide des différents professionnels de
santé parce qu'en réalité c'est par les
vaccinateurs qui manquent
ça en a c'est les vaccins tout
simplement donc aujourd'hui on est dans
une campagne de com où on va se
retrouver à mettre tous dans des
vaccinaux droit au détriment
effectivement de certains territoires
qui vont avoir plus de mal à trouver des
d'autres au détriment de médecins qui
vont avoir plus de mal à avoir des doses
et par rapport à l'astra et n'est qu'à
par exemple qu'il ya une mauvaise
publicité des gens qui le boude
complètement parce que ils ont pas ils
connaissent pas le médecin qui les
entretiens
avant la vaccination ils ont pas
forcément confiance alors que si ça se
passait avec leur médecin habituel leur
médecin de famille peut-être que la
discussion engagée permettrait de les
convaincre de faire ce vaccin que c'est
un objectif ou pierre gonzalez
évidemment on touche au coeur du
problème le manque de doses chez vous
les pharmaciens et les généralistes
tirent également la sonnette d'alarmé
ils ont peu de doses à leur disposition
pour vacciner leurs patients
oui effectivement on a un peu de 2 mai à
faire tout est bon à prendre dans nos
dans notre situation donc je crois que
il faut que la population comprenne que
tous les vaccins sont utiles et que
faire de la sélection sera pas le
système idéal
il faudra absolument que on se persuade
que le que le risque encouru est
nettement plus faible que le bénéfice et
qui sera au bout du compte pour nous
c'est capital que les gens comprennent
qu'il faut se faire vacciner aujourd'hui
et que nous mettons tout en oeuvre nous
et en nos campagnes la plus reculée pour
que ça se fasse le plus vite possible
mais effectivement le sud des centrales
c'est le nombre de doses c'est évident
pardonnez moi oui pierre hurmic
justement sur cette question dès des
vaccins de la confiance un les doses ça
de toute façon voilà on n'a pas bien le
choix on les attendra mais où concernant
justement ce choix de weixin vous allez
avoir le choix vous justement où
vaccinodromes de bordeaux comment ça va
se passer comment vous allez gérer cette
question vous allez essayer de faire de
la pédagogie
oui puis l'avantagent simuler des
vaccinodromes c'est pour ça que c'est et
choisissez qu' on peut faire du fac du
pin isère
c'est à dire de l'iphone messager qui ne
peut se conserver que dans des
conditions de froid exceptionnelle qu'on
peut pas faire en médecine de ville
c'est un peu plus compliqué or
actuellement tout le monde réclame du
faillitaire et s'est fait comme ça a été
dit la santé des cas est un peu est un
peu boudé donc les grands centres offre
des facilités de conservation que nous
serons pas forcément tous des petits
centres de proximité mais je prends
comme un peu aussi impatiemment
vous allez d'ailleurs à l'époque
population il faut il faut les rassurer
bien entendu en tant que mère moi je
vais tout faire pour les inciter ce que
je fais déjà depuis quelques temps à
aller se faire vacciner le plus
rapidement possible j'ai envie d'aider
quel que soit le type de vaccin
actuellement l'urgence des gens c'est de
se faire vacciner
et j'ajoute qu'on attend avec impatience
ici comme ailleurs l'affairé des vaccins
johnson and johnson qui présente le
mérite inouïe d'avoir une seule une
seule vaccination
donc quand je vous parlais tout à
l'heure d'aller vers les gens aller vers
les gens en iran le jour on sera en
mesure de la garantir qu'une seule
vaccination suffit et pour ça il nous
faut rapidement je crois que celles
annoncées pour un peu près mi-avril le
vaccin johnson geste simple qui va tous
nous mettre d'accord par sa facilité de
sa facilité de doses uniques
alors il ya d'autres annonces a en tout
cas du gouvernement qui peuvent être
sujettes à caution on va voir des
vaccins anti qu'ovide fabriqué en france
et les dates de lancement regarder cette
carte des vaccins donc produit en france
la france qui va en quelque sorte servir
de sous traitants là aussi beaucoup de
communication une manière pour le
gouvernement de de marquer son
territoire mais tout de même il faut
comprendre que les entreprises n'ont
qu'un rôle de sous-traitant et elles ne
pourront pas faire de miracle si on ne
leur fournit pas assez de ces principes
actifs pour que le vaccin soit efficace
n'est ce pas karim khelfaoui
il faut se passe mais fier mais alors ça
ne veut pas dire qu'on va être tout d'un
coup enseveli de vaccins en france alors
pas du tout parce que réalité comme vous
l'avez dit c'est encore une nouvelle
campagne de communication
parce que par exemple sur le fait
d'obliger tech
il ne s'agit pas de produire du vaccin
en france mais de faire de la sous
traitance sur l'enfant flaconnage tout
simplement
donc on n'est pas du tout dans quelque
chose on va produire quelque chose
le vaccin en france c'est pas ça et puis
surtout on a toujours la même le même
problème qui est qu'il ya d'autres
vaccins qui sont disponibles et vous
disiez tout à l'heure on est on va être
obligés d'attendre des doses mais non
c'est pas vrai la campagne a commencé en
décembre
en décembre il était possible de prendre
une décision politique qui consistait à
dire nous avons besoin des vaccins
nous allons lever les brevets il c'est
possible et dans la loi c'est une
décision politique à prendre donc nous
allons mettre en marche l'industrie
pharmaceutique française la
réquisitionner pour fabriquer toutes les
doses dont nous avons besoin ça on
estime qu'il faut quatre mois pour
mettre la machine en branle et et créer
tout ce qu'il fallait comme celle de
production si ça avait été fait en
décembre
aujourd'hui effectivement serait en
train de produire tous les vaccins dont
on avait besoin
ça n'a pas été fait et ce n'est toujours
pas fait et on voudra vous sortir
l'argument ça ne se fait pas du jour au
lendemain ben oui ben n'étant comprend
pas la décision politique il ya rien qui
se fera ça c'est évident et ensuite à
côté de ça il ya d'autres vaccins qui
sont disponibles mais qui sont boudés
par les autorités et notamment les
autorités françaises je pense aux
vaccins russe qui a démontré une
efficacité dans des études avec revue
par les pairs notamment dans the lands
est donc à plus de discussions sur
l'efficacité de ce vaccin
et pourtant il ya toujours qu'une
commande on nous dit que c'est un
problème administratif qui bloque mais
enfin de quoi de qui on se moque
si on a besoin de vaccin aujourd'hui on
va voir les russes sont dit on
temps d'accès et puis on y va quoi et on
fait passer à l'année scène tous les
tests dont on a besoin pour s'assurer de
la sécurité du produit
et puis on fait pareil pour le vaccin
chinois et on fait pareil pour tous les
vaccins qui sont en train d'être
développé aujourd'hui on est bloqué sur
quelques entreprises occidentales parce
qu'il s'agit bien de géopolitique
c'est à dire qu'on a favorisé les
entreprises occidentales qui fabrique
c'est là que ça et on n'a commandé que
chez eux et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
bloquée parce qu'il ya une situation de
pénurie qui était facilement on pouvait
l'anticiper
on n'a pas un par idéologie on n'a pas
commandé ailleurs on n'a pas commandé
chez d'autres d'autres pays et on n'a
pas mis en place les moyens juridiques
et l'industriel pour faire en sorte que
l'on produise en france tout ce dont on
avait besoin donc le nombre de doses qui
nous manque aujourd'hui c'est un
problème politique c'est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement et de
personne d'autre
pierre hurmic le mot de la fin pour vous
alors concernant spoutnik v1 c'est vrai
que l'agencé européenne du médicament ne
se prononcera pas avant la fin juin
c'est vrai qu'il ya une lenteur qu'on
peut que remarquer vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse et ce sera le mot de
la fin pour vous de votre collègue karim
khelfaoui ce soir je suis pas médecin
mais je crois qu'effectivement il ya un
problème d'approvisionnement
et quand on est placé face à une pénurie
puisque actuellement c'est quand même
une pénurie je crois que toutes les
solutions
il ne faut en bout d aucune pour
comparis paunic vais une fois qu'il aura
subis elle et les contrôles européens
nécessaire je pense qu'il faut pas
s'aveugler sur une source de vaccin
plutôt que non je crois qu actuellement
il faut se donner les moyens de
diversifier au maximum une source
d'approvisionnement pour arriver ce tte
maxime cette oxydation bassil qui est
impatiemment attendue
merci à tous les trois messieurs pierre
hurmic hier philippe pardon grand alès
et karim khelfaoui d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
l'ukraine qui appelle l'otan accélérer
son adhésion pour envoyer je cite un
signal à la russie moscou qui estime que
cela ne ferait qu'empirer la situation
et puis direction ankara rencontre
aujourd'hui entre aurait fait perdre aux
années
les gens de l'union européenne la
turquie est un partenaire important de
l'ue ont ils rappelé
[Musique]
m
brigitte et pour tout ce que ça apporte
aux enfants
c'est une confiance confiance en soi ils
ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des gros poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et à écrire mais c'est pénalisant
pour l'enfant pour la famille on oublie
les parents qui sont responsables du
foyer est temps que les parents ne
maîtrise et ne parlent pas le français à
la maison basse avec difficile
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk
nous sommes au bord de la volga le plus
long fleuve d'europe nous sommes à
chevaux ksari allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier dernières
poches l'emprunt c'était en 2011 le
monde manque pas un petit peu non ah oui
c'est tous les fromages tous les soucis
sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne
savent pas je ne le pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la courge aux ennemis vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
20h38 les bienvenus en direct si vous
nous rejoignez sur rt france cnef en
appel à l'otan moscou met en garde
contre une dangereuse escalade depuis
plusieurs jours la tension est vive dans
l'est de l'ukraine d'une part et d'autre
de la frontière russe des poids des
militaires on retrouve à moscou notre
correspondante one claireaux bonsoir
antoine le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères s'est donc exprimé ce matin
concernant la dégradation de la
situation dans le donbass
oui en effet depuis fin décembre 2020 le
cessez le feu qui durait depuis six mois
c'est peu à peu désagrégée le conflit
fait de nouveau des morts
une hausse des tensions qui a provoqué
des déplacements de troupes russes au
sein du territoire russe des mouvements
de troupe qui font craindre à l'ukraine
une opération d'envergure le kremlin
assure que la russie ne constitue une
menace pour personne et s'inquiète
seulement de sa propre sécurité
son côté moscou tient kiev pour
responsables de la détérioration de la
situation sur place et regrette la
position des capitales occidentales ce
soutien inconditionnel envers l'ukraine
en dépit du manque de volonté politique
concernant la mise en oeuvre d un corps
de minsk mais aussi à propos de son
activité militaire au niveau de la ligne
de contact
écoutez mitchum tony cragg london la
réaction de nos collègues occidentaux au
renforcement de l'infrastructure
militaire et au transfert des troupes
vers la ligne de contact dans le dôme
basse est décevante
de toute évidence nos collègues
occidentaux continuent à partir du
principe qu'il faut systématiquement
soutenir les autorités ukrainiennes
même leurs activités et déclarations les
plus inacceptables
l'histoire alors la position du ministre
russe des affaires étrangères n'est pas
nouvelle il estime que l'ukraine ne fait
pas sa part du travail n'applique pas
les accords de minsk en particulier le
volet politique de ce texte pour
débloquer la situation sur le terrain le
cren pense à se rapprocher de l'otan
ou tout à fait en réponse à ce regain de
tension le président ukrainien volodimir
zielinski a appelé à accélérer
l'adhésion de son pays au sein de l'otan
seule solution d'après lui pour mettre
fin au conflit dans le donbass mais
aussi envoyer un signal fort à la russie
du côté de moscou cette initiative a été
accueillie de façon dubitative écoutez
nous doutons profondément que cela
puisse aider l'ukraine à résoudre son
problème interne
selon nous cela ne fera qu aggraver
davantage la situation parce qu'on ne
peut pas adhérer à l'otan sans prendre
en compte l'opinion publique
si vous demandez aux plusieurs millions
de personnes habitant les républiques
autoproclamées vous comprendrez que pour
l adhésion à l'otan est une perspective
tout à fait inacceptable car avoir un
nouveau pays membre de l'alliance
atlantique à sa frontière serait sans
aucun doute très mal vécue par les
autorités russes qui voit depuis
toujours l'extension de l'otan vers
l'est comme une véritable menace pour sa
sécurité
merci antoine gayraud en direct de
moscou
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
de gliniasty directeur de recherche à
l'iris ancien diplomate français bonsoir
jean de gliniasty merci d'être avec nous
le président ukrainien qui veut donc
accélérer on vient d'entendre l'entrée
de son pays dans l'otan cela risque-t-il
d'accentuer les tensions comme le
dénonce au dmitri peskov
alors bien entendu c'est une ligne rouge
pour la russie mais il faut rappeler que
toute adhésion le temps sera décidé à
l'unanimité des 27 ou des 25 membres de
l'otan et déjà il y avait eu une
tentative 2008 semaine bucarest et à
l'époque la france et l'allemagne
s'étaient opposés à ce qu'on appelle le
même match et pacsés chine française
c'est à dire un système
l' adhésion accélérée à l'otan qui avait
été proposé par les américains et les
français les allemands s'y sont opposés
mais ils ont dû malheureusement cédé sur
un point c'est qu'à la fin du communiqué
il y avait quand même que à terme la
géorgie et c'était la géorgie à l'époque
aussi et l'ukraine entrerait dans l'otan
est évidemment l'ukraine s'appuie sur ce
communiqué pour insister en permanence
pour entrer dans le temps et demande qui
est appuyé par un certain nombre d'états
membres de cette organisation
justement à le ministre ukrainien des
affaires étrangères souhaite une
position plus active de la france et de
l'allemagne au sein de de ce format
normandie ça veut dire que on se
rapproche justement de cette entrée dans
l'otan selon vous je ne crois pas parce
que je crois que les diplomaties de
nombreux pays européens savent que ça
serait un pas de plus vers une
déflagration il ya l'expérience de 2014
est dans toutes les têtes
donc non je ne je ne crois pas en
revanche on constate en effet que la
diplomatie ukrainienne cherche à élargir
le format d'un bandit puisque
l'allemagne et la france sont justement
des pays qui sont très réticents à
l'entrée de de l'ukraine dans le temps
et donc l'élargir il ya cette fameuse
plateforme de crimée où qui remplacerait
ok révocation remplacer le format
normandie avec la participation des
etats-unis de la grande-bretagne
éventuellement de la pologne pour
élargir en quelque sorte le spectre de
des pays qui négocie et dans un sens
évidemment plutôt favorable à ceux qui
sont favorables à l'entrée le temps
quand vous dites la france et
l'allemagne en une certaine manière
conscience d'une déflagration
cela risque on imagine d'être oui c'est
à dire qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'elle
veut qu'elles ont seraient les
conséquences justement
à pour les diplomaties française et
allemande je pense qu'ils éviteront
d'arriver jusqu'à un point où il y aura
un engrenage une escalade se mettrait en
place ça c'est sûr en tout cas le
kremlin de son côté n'a pas nié à elle
son mouvement de troupes mais insiste
sur le fait qu'il ne menace personne ça
suffit pour restaurer la confiance selon
vous ben on est dans une période un peu
bizarre parce qu'un nouveau président
américain qui utilisent des termes assez
peu diplomatique pour qualifier son
homologue russe
il y à une montée en puissance
incontestable de l'armée ukrainienne
il ya des manoeuvres de l'otan qui vont
avoir lieu je ne sais pas si elles sont
confirmées avec sa pelle defender qui
devait avoir lieu le lendemain derniers
qui devront avoir lieu cette année il y
a donc maintenant le renforcement du
dispositif russe à la frontière donc
c'est clair qu'on est dans une période
au moins verbale d'escaladé pas
seulement verbale les iob en tout cas
une période de tension qui s'apparente
un peu un test avant une prochaine étape
qui on peut l'espérer sera quand même
une étape de négociations mais pas
forcément d'affrontements alors en
russie on estime que l'ukraine serait
peut-être prête à attaquer se sentant
justement soutenu par washington et son
nouveau président ça vous semble être
crédible je ne crois pas non je ne crois
pas je ne crois pas que les puissances
occidentales laisseront l'ukraine
attaqué il ya eu des précédents en
géorgie ou ailleurs je crois que
l'expérience est là et personne n'a
envie d'avoir un conflit au coeur de
l'europe et surtout mettant en cause des
pays membres de l'otan
le
russie des puissances nucléaires donc
tout cela je pense qu'on n'ira pas
jusque là en tout cas il faut l'espérer
en tout cas malgré un désaccord de paix
en signant le rappel en 2015 à minsk et
plusieurs rencontres entre les
présidents russe et ukrainien sont sous
parrainage aux allemands et français
il semblerait que le règlement politique
du conflit soit au point mort ça veut
dire que les accords de minsk ne valent
plus rien aujourd'hui
il y à des tentatives récentes de
réactiver les accords de 2005 à des
propositions qui ont été faites par
l'allemagne et la france
desclaux stères de négociation des
feuilles de route qui ont appelé des
commentaires pas très encourageant
d'ailleurs née d'ukraine ni de la russie
est donc en saxe ce processus de
réactivation par est enlisée mais je ne
suis pas au coeur de la négociation
en tout cas il ya une vraie tentative de
maintenir en vie les les accords de
minsk cela dit on sait très bien que les
interprétations russes et des
interprétations ukrainienne des accords
de minsk sont sont différentes
j'ai tendance à penser que la
l'interprétation russe est plus conforme
à la lettre de désaccord de minsk mêler
les autres membres du groupe de minsk
essaye de trouver une formulation
moyenne et il n'y arrive pas
donc les accords de minsk en tout cas je
ne pense pas qu'il soit mort mais en
tout cas ils sont enlisés à l'heure
actuelle ou en tout cas dans une passe
difficile
merci jean de gliniasty directeur de
recherche à l'iris ancien diplomate
français de nous avoir apporté votre
analyse et en russie sept
interpellations de journalistes de la
chaîne cnn il était venu courir un
rassemblement de partisans d'un
excellent navalni devant à la prison où
l'opposant est incarcéré les
manifestants dont plusieurs médecins
espérer recueillir des informations sur
l'état de santé de l'opposant et demandé
également son transfert vers un hôpital
de moscou pour y être soignés plusieurs
d'entre eux ont été arrêtés ainsi que
des journalistes donc de shenzhen venus
couvrir ce rassemblement selon les
autorités russes ces derniers n'auraient
pas obtempéré aux injonctions des forces
de l'ordre
selon les informations disponibles des
correspondants de la chaîne de
télévision américaine cnn se trouvaient
entre autres sur la chaussée menant à
l'établissement pénitentiaire
lorsque les représentants des forces de
l'ordre leur ont demandé de s'écarter du
chemin car il entrave est le
fonctionnement de l'établissement
spéciales et le passage des véhicules et
le non respect de ces règles peut
entraîner des poursuites
les journalistes ont refusé ils n'ont
pas non plus montré leur carte
d'accréditation par la suite la police a
arrêté plusieurs personnes dont les
journalistes susmentionnés pour
l'instant ces représentants des médias
se trouve au poste de police jusqu'à ce
que toutes les circonstances de la
sphère soit clarifiée rencontre
aujourd'hui en turquie du président du
conseil européen et de la commission
européenne avec le président turc
objectif de l'entrevue discuter des
modalités de la reprise des relations
économiques et aborder les sujets qui
divisent le ton a été donné dès ce mardi
pour avancer dans le processus de
réconciliation apparemment souhaité par
ankara
il va falloir que la turquie reconsidère
la question des droits humains comme l'a
souligné hier cela van der leyen
je suis profondément préoccupés par le
retrait de la turquie de la convention
d'istanbul
il s'agit là de protéger les femmes de
protéger les enfants contre les
violences dont ils sont victimes
sortir de cette convention est un très
mauvais signal
l'état de droit et le respect des droits
fondamentaux sont des valeurs
essentielles de l'union européenne et
nous avons fait part au président et aux
douanes de nos profondes inquiétudes
quant aux derniers développements
turquie à cet égard notamment en ce qui
concerne la liberté d'expression et la
prise pour cible des partis politiques
et des médias
donc le dialogue avec la turquie
retour en images sur des relations
compliquées depuis des années
[Musique]
il
pourquoi
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
olivier delorme historien écrivain
auteur de la grèce et des balkans aux
éditions gallimard
bonsoir olivier delorme alors cette
visite en turquie de charles michel et
vendeurs à ursula von der leyen à ce
qu'elles étaient indispensables c'était
urgent de renouer le dialogue a
certainement pas on donne là un très
mauvais signal erdogan qui n'a fait
aucune concession sur aucun dossier en
allant chez lui pour en quelque sorte
renouer un dialogue qui n'a jamais été
rompu et alors que on a pris des
sanctions qui n'en sont pas alors que la
turquie multiplie les provocations à
l'égard de l'union européenne et
notamment à l'égard de deux de ses
membres chypre et et la grèce tout au
long de l'été il n'y a eu aucune détente
il n'y a eu aucun progrès dans les dents
les discussions gréco-turque piot qui
ont repris il il n'y a eu aucune
concession d'erdogan sur les droits de
l'homme
au contraire il a lancé une procédure
d'interdiction du parti du seul parti en
réalité qui est pour une véritable
démocratie en turquie et est de surcroît
aujourd'hui erdogan enfin des personnes
de la de l'entourage de rigueur rigueur
de gan
revoir la finance ou montreux sur la
circulation dans les détroits
donc je dirais que c'était une fois de
plus une erreur d'analysé stratégique de
l'union européenne d'aller à canossa
danser dans ces conditions là c'est
aussi un échec de la position soutenue
par emmanuel macron la position de
fermeté envers la turquie
à écouter en tout cas emmanuel macron a
envoyé des des forces et notamment le
groupe aéronaval français avec le porte
avions charles de gaulle qui se trouve
aujourd'hui en méditerranée orientale
donc la france a une position de de
soutien à la grèce et à chypre dans la
défense de leur souveraineté et et du
droit international puisque la turquie
viol dans cette affaire le droit de la
mer et les conventions du droit de la
mer donc donc un maquereau à une
position qui est une position qui est
une position logique mais ils sortent à
un une allemagne qui exercent des
pressions pas sensé sur l'union
européenne pour empêcher toute sanction
à l'égard de la turquie et on va
aujourd'hui problème malheureusement de
plus beau à hasnon alors que vous
m'entendez plus la liaison vous un petit
peu perdues monsieur de leurs ballons et
s'est essayée vedette de reprendre votre
propos vous avez perdu quelques secondes
malheureusement je disais qu'un alors où
la turquie recommence à utiliser larmes
des migrants en faisant débarquer de
nouveaux de nouveaux migrants dans les
îles grecques
c'est ce et c'est très contre-productif
de la part de l'union européenne une
poussée par l'allemagne sur laquelle
elle
l'allemagne exerce des pressions insensé
en faveur de la turquie aujourd'hui
d'aller négocier et d'aller négocier
notamment d'après ce qu'on nous dit de
nouvelle aide financière à la turquie
alors que la turquie est effectivement
dans une situation financière
extrêmement problématique puisque la
livre et et ans est en chute libre
depuis le dernier changement le
quatrième en quatre ans de gouverneur de
la banque centrale par air de gan de
manière complètement erratiques donc la
monnaie turquie est en chute libre et on
va aller proposer à erdogan sans aucune
contrepartie une aide financière et
éditons des facilités des facilités pour
accorder des visas aux turcs eux dans
l'union européenne
donc si vous voulez septembre en europe
at elle le choix puisque l'on sait
ankara exerce une forme de chantage sur
la question migratoire
écoutez on n'a jamais on n'a jamais on
n'a jamais arrêté
les jours et qui font des coups de force
en en allant de négocier avec eux c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui l'union européenne
devrait devrait on compte tout au
contraire fixer des lignes rouges
précise ar dogan et faire savoir à
erdogan qu' il n'a pas le droit
d'utiliser cette arme des migrants et
non pas essayer et n'ont pas cédé à
chaque fois à son chantage
donc si vous voulez la question
aujourd'hui c'est que l'on devrait avoir
à l'égard de d'ankara une politique de
fermeté et que au contraire sous la
pression de l'allemagne
on a une politique de faiblesse alors il
ya quand même ce rappel à l'ordre sur
les droits humains cette mise sous
condition et lé symbole et pour vous
écouter tout ça tout ça et tout ça est
totalement théorie puisque derrière les
sanctions kaka
le cas adopter l'union européenne à
reculons alors que chypre et la grèce
demant et la france demandent de réelles
sanctions depuis des mois madame merkel
a mis son veto à toute véritable
sanction
j'ajouterai madame merkel et l'espagne
qui est gavé dont les banques sont très
engagés dans la tête étaient turcs et
qui a aujourd'hui très peur que la
turquie fasse défaut donc si vous voulez
on a une fois de plus à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne des intérêts
divergents qui font que la position
européenne est totalement incohérente et
que on va caresser dans le sens du poil
quelqu'un qui agresse depuis des mois et
des mois de deux états membres de
l'union européenne
donc si vous venez tout ça allait
absolument à incohérent et montre une
fois de plus qu'on n'ait pas plus forts
à 27 dans l'union européenne
parce qu'à 27 on a des on a des intérêts
divergents et que la position commune
est toujours le plus petit dénominateur
commun entre les vingt-sept et on ne
fait pas une politique vis-à-vis de
quelqu'un qui agit de manière cynique et
avec des coups de force on ne fait pas
de politique
avec un plus petit dénominateur commun
merci beaucoup olivier delorme historien
et écrivain auteur de la grèce et des
balkans d'avoir été avec moi en direct
sur rt france
dans le reste de l'actualité en israël
après deux jours de consultations des
différents partis politiques le
président revienne rivlin a de nouveau
choisi benyamin nétanyahou qui a réagi
aujourd'hui en affirmant qu'il ferait
tout pour sortir son pays de la spirale
des élections le premier ministre
sortant de plus en plus contesté après
douze années au pouvoir et dont le
procès pour corruption a débuté ce lundi
doit former un gouvernement de coalition
stable et sortir l'état hébreu d'une
impasse politique de plusieurs années
les explications
j'ai pris ma décision sur la base des
recommandations des partis qui indique
que le député benjamin netanyahu a les
meilleures chances de former un
gouvernement
ce n'est pas une décision facile pour
moi tant moralement qu'éthiquement
[Musique]
beaucoup
le président a accompli son devoir et
n'avait pas le choix mais confié le
mandat à netanyahou est une honte qui
ternit israël et fait honte à notre
statut d'état respectueux des lois
[Musique]
le premier ministre netanyahu désigné
pour former le gouvernement choix qui
divise les israéliens écoutez si
benjamin netanyahu réussi à former un
gouvernement ce dont je doute un peu à
cause de tous les boycotts mais c'est un
gouvernement est formé que ce soit par
netanyahou ou par un autre candidat je
pense qu'il ne tiendra pas nous sommes
dans une situation le gouvernement ne
sont pas homogènes ils sont tellement
dépendants d'éléments radicaux de droite
et de gauche qu'ils ne peuvent pas
cohabiter avec la même idéologie et la
même politique et à mon grand regret tôt
ou tard je pense que nous nous dirigeons
vers une cinquième élection lors des
précédents tours les gens étaient contre
netanyahou
mais quoi qu'il fasse il est élu encore
et encore le problème ce sont ces partis
qui boycotte
c'est juste de la haine s'il n'y avait
pas cette haine le likoud aurait gagné
avec 80 % des voix mais que pouvons-nous
faire quand il ya une telle guerre
politique je pense que tous les
politiciens ont trop d'ego intel ne veut
pas travailler avec tel autre
celui là ne veut pas former un
gouvernement avec celui ci ils sont tous
les uns contre les autres et c'est
dommage car au final nous voulons tous
la même chose
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur ce premier jour en
distance yale pour les élèves des écoles
collèges et lycées non sans mal à
distance notamment pour les parents et
puis nous parlerons des campagnes de
vaccination supposait accéléré avec
l'ouverture de vaccinodromes répartis
sur tout le territoire le virage
sanitaire opérée par le gouvernement
sera-t-il suffisant on en parlera avec
alexis poulain
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
les trente ans que les cours sont
manipulés comment est-ce qu'on peut
réguler ça on ne peut pas c'est une
manipulation on va dire 2 0 la
possibilité de cette manipulation est
encore plus facile parce que vous avez
de nouveaux traders parce que vous avez
des gens qui ont été attirés par
l'argent assez facile le bitcoin
illustre quelque chose qui existe de
toute éternité gagner de l'argent en ne
faisant rien en achetant un actif qui
nous vaut intrinsèquement rien grâce à
des gogos qui n'y comprennent rien sauf
la promesse de faire fortune qui en
profitent réellement de ces
manipulations pour malheureusement c'est
pas les petites sardines c'est des
requins le petit particulier il est là
pour ce faire pour
[Musique]
on
comment vous jugez vous la situation
aujourd'hui après plus d'un an de crise
le tourisme est probablement l'une des
filières qui souffrent le plus de la
crise sanitaire le tourisme et
l'événementiel c'est à dire en fait tout
ce qui crée des flux de population tout
ce qui crée des rassemblements comment
vous voyez là les possibilités de faire
redémarrer tout ça le rôle des élus en
ce moment qu'ils soient nationaux ou
locaux
c'est de trouver le juste équilibre
entre la protection sanitaire et donc la
disparition du virus à terme et la vie
économique et la vie sociale
on voit bien que y'a pas que la vie
économique qui est touché il a toute la
psychologie des gens c'est trop long
donc il faut ajuster les protocoles
sanitaires à une vie économique
culturelle sportive événementielle qui
puisse renaître
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici l'équipe de l'actualité de
ce mardi 6 avril premier jour andy
essentielle pour les écoles collèges et
lycées des difficultés pour se connecter
en raison de serveurs numériques
inaccessible défaillant la france qui
vise sur l'accélération de la
vaccination avec l'ouverture de
vaccinodromes comme en seine saint denis
aujourd'hui
côté production la france doivent
conditionner des l'ex1 partir de demain
sur le territoire mais n'est-ce que
symbolique
on en parlera avec avec ses poulains de
notre rubrique les dix tours
[Musique]
la france entre dans son troisième
confinement l'espagne elle craint une
quatrième vague alors que le nombre de
cas augmente tout comme la propagation
des variants outre atlantique la
situation continue de se dégrader au
brésil plus de 3000 personnes décèdent
quotidiennement du virus bien plus que
pendant le pic de la première vague
l'état vole au secours d'air france la
compagnie aérienne touchés de plein
fouet depuis un an par la crise
sanitaire obtient une aide de 4
milliards d'euros
une recapitalisation autorisée par la
commission européenne l'état va aussi
devenir le premier actionnaire
en contrepartie la compagnie devra céder
18 créneaux horaires à orly
[Musique]
là
finie la tolérance la france
métropolitaine est entrée dans son
troisième confinement pour une durée de
quatre semaines
parallèlement mesures de restriction le
gouvernement compte sur la vaccination
pour endiguer d'épidémie la cadence
supposé accéléré dès aujourd'hui avec
l'ouverture aux quatre coins du pays de
vaccinodromes une quarantaine au total
une semaine qui marque également la
fermeture des classes écoles collèges et
lycées ont renoué avec l'enseignement à
distance avant les vacances de printemps
et de nombreux bugs ont été signalés par
les professeurs parents et lèvres en
cause des serveurs numériques
inaccessibles ou défaillants jean michel
blanquer a assuré pourtant que le
dispositif numérique de l'éducation
nationale était prêt pour un nouveau
confinement est alors que la réouverture
des écoles pourrait bien dépendre de la
vaccination des enseignants la campagne
a du mal à prendre forme l'objectif
annoncé du gouvernement semble
difficilement réalisable
david khalifa des actions et du concret
pour respecter la nouvelle priorité de
l'exécutif vacciner l'ensemble des
enseignants voilà ce que réclament les
syndicats sauf que le flou demeure suite
aux récentes déclarations de certains
membres du gouvernement aux libéraux et
jean michel blanquer ont du mal à
accorder leurs violons
le ministre de la santé avait clairement
affiché sa volonté de vacciner la
totalité à des enseignants au lendemain
à des annonces des manuels macron avant
que le ministre de l'éducation nationale
tempère et parle d'un ciblage progressif
au sein du corps enseignant
s'agissant des professeurs notre
objectif c'est que ce soit dans le
courant du mois d'avril selon des règles
de priorité que nous travaillons
actuellement notamment ça commencera par
ceux qui s'occupent des enfants en
situation de handicap
on continuera normalement avec ceux qui
s'occupent des enfants de maternelle et
puis ensuite ce sera un raisonnement
parages tout ce travail se fait
actuellement avec les autorités de santé
avec ses projections les enseignants
pourront espérer être vaccinés à la mi
juin un manque de clarté qui agacent les
syndicats pointent du doigt encore une
fois en manque d'anticipation de la part
du gouvernement pour ouvrir sereinement
les écoles il faudrait vacciner
massivement les personnels et les
professeurs par ailleurs les chiffres
prouvent que les variants du coroner des
russes ont changé là
et que les écoles sont devenus de
véritables lieux à risque de
contamination élevé élèves et
professeurs et personnels confondus les
tests positifs au coc u19 se sont
multipliés ces dernières semaines
d'où l'inquiétude d'une ouverture trop
précoce des écoles nous ce qu'on demande
c'est pas de passer avant des personnes
qui seraient vulnérables
c'est d'avoir une politique vaccinale où
on dise clairement quand est-ce qu'on
vaccine les uns et les autres
quand est-ce qu'on peut du coup avoir
une réouverture sécuriser des
établissements scolaires et des écoles
et qu'on puisse du coup dire on protège
les personnels parce qu'on les fait
revenir au contact des élèves des
usagers etc
donc c'est une volonté d'avoir une
visibilité sur ce qui va être fait et
pour l'instant on ne l'a pas on a une
forme de déni des réalités et du coup un
manque d'anticipation
on découvre les sujets au dernier moment
un déni de réalité qui se traduit par un
retard certain sur d'autres pays
européens selon une étude de l'os et des
oeufs en mars 2021 dans 19 pays et sur
les enseignants sont prioritaires pour
la vaccination
l'espoir affiché par emmanuel macron
reste utopique même en prenant compte
les nouvelles livraisons de vaccins mi
avril
la france compte 1,2 million
d'enseignants et d'agents de l'éducation
nationale une petite partie a déjà pu
bénéficier du vaccin car allah répondait
aux critères des règles communes
mais le défi logistique reste immense en
ajoutant à l'ouverture de la vaccination
aux personnes de plus de 60 ans à la
mi-avril sans compter l'ouverture de la
campagne aux forces de l'ordre également
prévue à la fin du mois la bataille
risque d'être très long pour les
enseignants et pour parler de cette
semaine de cours à distance qui s'ouvre
nous sommes avec philippe renaud vice
président de la fcpe du val d'oise
bonsoir il
merci d'être avec nous alors avant toute
chose comment s'est passée cette
première journée d'école à distance pour
vous annoncer qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
bugs un peu partout en france c'était le
cas également chez vous oui bonsoir
alors effectivement on va dire que la
matinée a été assez catastrophique
moi j'ai des tas de parents qui m'ont
appelé ou par sms ou par mail est le mot
qui revenait tout le temps pour ses
excès d parce que ça va juste pas marché
alors c'est à dire ça n'a pas marché ça
veut dire qu'il y avait quand même des
des courants vision qui étaient prévues
dans la plupart des cas c'est ça chez
vous ça dépense dire que c'était plutôt
par niveau c'est à dire que sur les
écoles maternelles élémentaires
ce n'est pas tellement des cours qui
était prévu il ya eu des pochettes donné
il ya eu des choses mois après il
fallait se connecter pour dire où on en
était donc les système marchait pas très
bien en collège par contre on passait de
toute présence à tous distance donc bah
c'était quand même compliqué pour les
professeurs au dernier moment
d'organiser quelque chose et découvrir
ce matin qu'on n'y avaient pas accès
parce que les serveurs marchait pas
ouais c'était vraiment vraiment pas une
bonne bonne surprise yahoo qui sépare l
ouïe au lycée c'est pareil bien sûr
philippe renault il ya aussi quelque
chose dont on parle peu parce qu'il ya
souvent une communication de la part
notamment du ministre de l'éducation qui
nous explique d'ailleurs lors du premier
confinement que tout s'était très bien
passée l'enseignement à distance qui
remerciait les professeurs mais il ya
quand même beaucoup d'inégalités enfin
vous m'arrêtez si je me trompe
m'envoyait certaines écoles qui bras qui
ne donne que des devoirs il n'y a pas du
tout de visio ya rien quand d'autres ont
peut-être de la visioconférence toute la
journée ça devient compliqué peut-être
aussi pour les parents à gérer ce
problème d'inégalité effectivement long
on le voit où l'entend on le ressent
parce que même à l'intérieur d'un
établissement ça peut dépendre aussi de
ça on va dire de la motivation mais
surtout de l'équipement des professeurs
parce qu'ils n'ont pas tous ce qu'il
faut ça dépend aussi de bas du service
informatique fin de des systèmes
informatiques des établissements parce
que
avec les lois de décentralisation c'est
les mairies c'est voilà des
collectivités territoriales et c'est
assez inégal donc oui et après pour les
enfants eux mêmes c'est pareil dans les
familles je veux dire il ya des familles
où on est équipé on a de la place on
arrive à le faire bien il ya d'autres
familles c'est très très compliqué de le
faire donc on a vu des forts décrochages
au premier confinement nous craint
énormément de revoir les mêmes mais ça
veut dire que du côté en tout cas des
professeurs il n'y a pas vraiment
d'obligations télétravail si j'ose dire
c'est vrai que dans le privé on connaît
tous le télétravail et il ya une
obligation voilà d'être présents devant
son ordinateur pour les profs n'y a pas
d'obligation finalement d'être là et
surtout on ne leur en donnent pas
toujours les moyens aussi
alors ils en n'ont pas toujours les
moyens il ya une obligation et travail
après c'est pas pour ça qu'ils font leur
travail sous forme de cours à distance
ça peut être parfois des choses qui sont
donnés aux élèves et des professeurs
sont juste là pour être disponible pour
pour répondre à des questions où il ya
des contrôles qu'ont lieu plus tard donc
voila mais d'ailleurs c'est un peu
l'ambiguïté c'est quand on parle de
cours à distance ces infos mots c'est on
appelle ça une continuité pédagogique et
ensuite chaque enseignant on va dire est
libre de la façon dont ils appliquent
motif est en fait il doit faire
respecter les programmes et doit
continuer à ce que les élèves suivent
après il le fait de fait à sa façon mais
ça génère de l'incompréhension chez les
familles et la frustration et
l'énervement
effectivement alors vous c'est important
de dire quelle va être cpe vous ne
demandez pas la fermeture des écoles et
pourtant les classes fermer les unes
après les autres avant ce confinement
aujourd'hui quel est votre sentiment il
n'y avait pas le choix
alors on était arrivés tard ce qui est
terrible c'est d'en être arrivé là parce
que effectivement ça fait un an que le
confinement et là je veux dire il ya un
an
d'ailleurs si on l'avait fait des choses
mais un an plus tard que ça soit
toujours pas prêt qui le bug de ce matin
c'était vraiment
voilà si on voulait être convaincu que
rien n'a été préparé
c'est bon on est convaincu mais voilà
mais nous on est fan on est désolé on ne
vendait pas on n'en est pas là fermeture
des écoles ont demandé qu'en fait il ya
un protocole on n'est pas médecin on
n'est pas les types épidémiologistes ont
demandé à ce que le protocole défini par
l'état soient appliquées il n'a pas été
appliquée parce qu'ils n'avaient pas des
personnels suffisants et n'y avait pas
les matériels
voilà ça manquait d'argent ça manquait
de personnes donc à la fin gouvernement
il avait pu la faire appliquer le
protocole donc bah il a décidé une
sphère du tout et ils ferment on se pose
comme question c'est à la rentrée parce
qu'il y aura une rentrée parents
l'espère comment ça va se passer qu'est
ce qui va se passer qu'est ce qu'il a
été alors on nous avait promis un tout
de même on s'en souvient des tests
salivaires c'était les grandes annonces
de des dernières conférences de presse
il ya quelques semaines d'olivier
ferrand et et de jean castex s'était
fait l'hiver dans les écoles vous en
avez vu la couleur où vit alors dans
notre département suit près avec avec
les autorités le rythme c'était à peu
près sur le val d'oise sur un seul
département c'était à peu près de 1000
par jour
ça fait un chiffre qui fait impression
qu on le multiplie par le nombre
d'élèves
c'est quand même pas énormément donc
c'était un début on attendait
l'accélération bombe à la toile on s'est
arrêté donc c'est pareil c'est à la
rentrée est ce qu'il y aura des moyens
décuplés pour tester plus fréquemment
est fréquemment et tous les élèves
en tout cas tous ceux dont les familles
souhaitent que ça soit fait ces foyers
on a surtout eu des villes de valade et
des associations et cpe dans des lits
qui disait bennoo quand est ce que sait
on jamais c'est l'hiver des villes
complètes ont pas eu test salivaire du
tout il ya aussi une autre chose que
qu'on attendait dans l'enseignement dans
l'éducation nationale c'était peut-être
la vaccination en priorité des
enseignants et ce appareil peut-être
douche froide avec la dernière
conférence de presse emmanuel macron
sauf erreur de ma part les enseignements
passeront
entre guillemets avec les autres à
partir du 15 mois en tout cas en
fonction de leur âge tout simplement
mais n'y a pas une priorisation il
aurait peut-être fallu le faire alors je
fais le même constat goût c'est à dire
qu'au début on a commencé à novembre que
les enseignants seraient vaccinés on
sait tous ce qui se passe sur le manque
de deux doses de vaccin redire au niveau
global
donc on avait énormément de doutes bon
allez limite là les doutes sont levés on
sait que les enseignants ce n'est pas
vacciné le 26 avril
quand l'école est censé reprendre dans
le premier degré et donc voilà j'ai
entendu mi juin tout à l'heure dans
votre documentaire bon mais me voilà
j'en sais rien mais mais non les
enseignants seront pas vaccinés à la
rentrée donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe voyez c'est quand
même ça qui est compliqué c'est que on
voit de l'improvisation au fur et à
mesure c'est toujours des décisions
prises au dernier moment et la même
trois semaines à l'avant ce qu'est ce
qui va se passer on sait rien on sent un
petit peu votre désarroi
c'est le cas de nombreux parents
évidemment en france aujourd'hui
vous pensez comme le gouvernement avait
l'air de dire que on a poussé au maximum
qu'on est resté le plus ouvert possible
dans l'est dans les écoles contrairement
aux autres pays où vous êtes quand même
inquiet pour cette nouvelle année
scolaire de nos enfants
plus qu'un pied parce que il ya
effectivement des anglais voilà il ya
des élèves qui sont voilà qu'avec nul
coup on va dire au premier trimestre
qu'on a fait les conseils de classe de
premier deuxième trimestre et au
deuxième trimestre ils ont commencé à
lâcher donc il ya toute une partie des
jeunes qui voilà qui voilà qui sont
partis que tak ont décroché on les verra
pas pendant qu'on filme en ce sens nous
on a les premières stats de combien
d'élèves étaient en visio pour les rares
visites organisées dans les lycées c'est
très bas mais après on a aussi le
problème inverse c'est à dire qu'on a
des élèves qui étaient bons voire très
bons c'est terrible à dire mais ils sont
en train de saturer c'est à dire que
dans les lycées on a vu en première et
en terminale les élèves qui sature qui
n'en peuvent plus
psychologiquement ils vont pas bien les
professeurs et l'administration enfin la
direction de mon lycée ont fait le même
constat est en place donc ça éclate par
les deux bouts et on voit rien c'est
important parce que ce qu'il faut
préciser que c'est que avant les
fermetures il y avait beaucoup de classe
sont déjà fermés et ça ça me met on
imagine ces jeunes samyn salines et les
familles en fête la semaine dernière il
y avait beaucoup de colère dans les
familles parce qu'on voyait arriver les
fermetures les unes après les autres et
personne n'osait trop le dire sauf que
ban où il est constaté
donc les familles étaient en colère donc
mercredi soir avec les annonces qui
avait un moment d'expectative on va dire
et puis ce matin la douche froide
c'est à dire que tout ce qui avait tenté
d'être mis en place par par des profs
qu'on bosse expliqué martin je veux dire
voilà et basse on irait jusqu'à ax et
donc je sais pas dans quel état à eux
aussi ils sont mais y'a rien je veux
dire on a l'impression qu'à rien on a
l'impression qu'ils rien ça fait un an
que ça dure
il ya un an on a tenu le coup il ya un
an il y avait des initiatives y avait de
l'énergie avec l'imagination de tout le
monde
on n'est plus dans cet état là les
parents sont fatigués excédés et les
jeunes des jeunes sont vraiment
moralement fatigué il ya un truc que je
voudrais demander sais pas si je peux
mais les épreuves terminales de français
et philo faut tout de suite dire qu'elle
passe en contrôle continu les gamins et
ça c'est pas possible de leur faire
subir ça encore longtemps
merci beaucoup en tout cas philippe
renaud vice président de la fcpe du du
val d'oise d'avoir été avec nous
déploiement progressif des vaccinodromes
et de la production de vaccin dès demain
sur tout le territoire les français
soumis un troisième confinement alors la
stratégie gouvernementale face au comité
sera t-elle au rendez vous pour en
parler nous sommes avec alexis poulain
c'est notre rubrique l'édito
un bon soir alexis poulain vaccinodromes
accélération de la stratégie sanitaire
ou futur fiasco alors les fiascos il y
en a eu beaucoup jusqu'à présent c'est
vrai les masques les tests les doses de
vaccins qui n'arrive pas et les
vaccinodromes et on commence à serrer
les dents c'est vrai que la france et
les vaccinodromes ce n'est pas une
histoire d'amour on se rappelle le h1n1
et roselyne bachelot alors ministre de
la santé qui avait ouvert à l'époque des
vaccinodromes qui sont restés
désespérément vides et aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron qui a rechigné à ouvrir
ces vaccinodromes justement compte tenu
de l'histoire ancienne de ceux de ce
h1n1 décide finalement de les ouvrir
mais voilà beaucoup de critiques à la
fois parce que les doses n'arrive pas
parce que les bâtis nos troupes sont en
train de siphonner les doses également
de vaccination départemental les
médecins les élus commencent à dénoncer
la perte de doses quotidiennes
journalières au profit de ces
vaccinodromes rien ne dit que les
français vont aller danser vaccinodromes
qui reste pour certains vides voir
qu'ils vont fermer parce que les doses
ne sont toujours pas là
on apprend aujourd'hui que pfizer qui
devrait livrer plusieurs millions de
doses à la fin du moral ne livra que
début juin
c'est le cas également d'astrazeneca les
laboratoires n'ont pas été au rendez
vous pourtant bercy a monté un commando
qui s'appelle la prod va qu avec un
ancien de sanofi des hauts
fonctionnaires du trésor de bercy de
l'industrie qui vont négocier avec les
laboratoires pour aller récupérer des
doses parce que finalement la politique
du en commun la politique de commander
via bruxelles n'a pas fonctionné ou à
fonctionner à en organisant la pénurie
mais on ne peut pas vraiment le dire
donc il va falloir récupérer ces doses
d'une façon ou d'une autre la prod
vagues peut-être réussir thierry breton
était très fier aussi de dire que la
production revenait sur le territoire
national il était en visite en côte d'or
à dijon à chenôve à côté de dijon
c'est loin d'être le cas en réalité ce
sont des sous traitants d'entreprises
allemandes ou ou internationales qui
vont produire des composants du vaccin
mais le vin
ça ne sera pas produit sur le territoire
français donc on est là en train de se
poser la question de dire est-ce que
encore un effet d annonce
encore un effet de communication qui va
faire pschitt ça commence à faire
beaucoup
et là ça commence je pense à rick était
également l'exécutif alors il ya une
autre annonce à la production en france
qui commence demain même si il faut le
préciser une partie des doses vont
partir à l'étranger
oui alors non seulement nous allons
produire sur le territoire français et
européens mais nous sommes fiers
d'exporter plus que nous en gardons sur
le territoire européen
et c'est vrai que au delà de produire le
problème des composants du vaccin reste
essentiel aujourd'hui nous sommes
tributaires de l'étranger nous ne sommes
pas indépendants sur la production de
doses de vaccins nous faisons de
l'embouteillage du flaconnage c'est à
dire que nous mettons les produits dans
des flacons nous faisons de la
production de nanoparticules denanot
lipides de d'outils qui vont permettre à
produire ce vaccin mais pour ce qui est
des composants ils ne sont pas produits
ici en france et sur le territoire
européen
c'est encore loin d'être le cas donc une
pénurie est possible égaler le fait de
dire que les vaccins sont françaises
c'est loin d'être le cas aujourd'hui
setzer bio ntech ses astra zeneca et
astrazeneca
on le voit il y à une défiance
grandissante des populations parce que
l'agencé européenne du médicament
commencé à avoir des doutes
c'est certaines thrombose veineuse qui
sont graves qui sont certes rares voire
extrêmement rare mais qui arrive et qui
pousse à la défiance vis-à-vis de cette
de ce vaccin
pourtant produit sur le sol européen ça
en fait beaucoup
et pourtant l'europe rechignent toujours
à commander des vaccins auprès de la
russie avec spoutnik v ou de la chine
ce sera uniquement en juin que
l'autorité européenne du médicament
donnera un avis pour la mise sur le
marché de ces vaccins là donc on est en
train d'organiser une pénurie
néanmoins et mener le maquereau et le
ministère de la santé reste optimiste et
continue de viser les dix millions de
primo vacciner en avril les 20 millions
en mai
et les 38 en juin ça on ne sait pas ça
commence à être un peu plus flou il ne
se cache pas que ce sera extrêmement
tendue parce que livraison n'arrive pas
au rythme demandé et la vaccinodromes ou
pas on reste dans le flou total
quant à ses objectifs et dans ce
contexte tendu et lexie la sphère
pierre-jean chalencon mais le
gouvernement un petit peu dans
l'embarras quand même hein et alors
c'est une journée exceptionnelle
c'est à la fois l'anniversaire de la
république en marche cinq ans que le
parti présidentiel a été créé et est
aujourd'hui il semblerait qu'à ministre
aurait été aperçu à un dîner clandestins
c'est la société des journalistes de m6
qui le dit dans un communiqué de presse
ce soir en faisant non nous ne faisons
pas d'échec news
nous enquêtons nous attendons de savoir
qui est cette personne
pourtant tout a été fait pour minimiser
cette affaire en disant que non c'était
un poisson d'avril pierre jean salençon
ce collectionneur femme de napoléon
propriétaire de l'hôtel de ville vienne
qui organise ces dîners est en train de
s'expliquer en disant qu'il est à
farceur et que c'était un poisson
d'avril
toute la cellule riposte du parti
présidentiel est vent debout pour dire
que c'est scandaleux de parler sans
savoir
néanmoins les journalistes de m6 en
quête d'autres journalistes
d'investigation sont en train d'essayer
de savoir qui était présent à ces dîners
clandestins et des dîners clandestins
oui il y en a et c'est insupportable
pour les français qui se voient eux
obligés de payer des amendes de 400
euros quand il débouche une bouteille de
rosé entre amis sur une plage alors que
faire jean salençon lui mettait les
photos de ces dîners sur les réseaux
sociaux en se vantant d'être l'ami de
brigitte macron des ministres est très
fière d'organiser ces dîners clandestins
il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas au
royaume de france
tout est en train d'un peu de se bloquer
comme les ent la façon de donner cours à
distance
aujourd'hui on pensait que le ministère
de l'éducation aurait été prêt un an
après alors que les écoles fermées
aujourd'hui à donner des cours en ligne
il n'en était rien jean michel blanquer
a tenté en vain d'accuser des hackers
étrangers d'ailleurs je crois que les
réseaux sociaux ne se sont pas privés de
se moquer de cette excuse
quelque chose qui ne marche plus chez en
marche et ça commence à se voir
oui je confirme les bugs aujourd'hui le
toit alexis dans une campagne politique
présidentielle qui s'installe valls
mélenchon jadot bertrand retailleau
philippa et j'en passe oui le climat est
exceptionnel c'est vrai que pour ses 5
ans en marche et gâtés il a beaucoup de
cadeaux d'anniversaire beaucoup de
candidats à la présidentielle alors les
candidats officiels déclaré marine le
pen qui essaye de se glisser dans la
peau d'une candidate mainstream un peu
policé qui va essayer de séduire la
droite traditionnelle et d'être cette
candidate de droite finalement et plus
d'extrême droite xavier bertrand qui va
essayer d'incarner un nouveau nicolas
sarkozy avec des valeurs de la droite le
travail et puis d'autres choses des
candidats à droite aussi qu'ils sont
soumis déclaré comme l'ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe qui n'osent
pas dire qu'il pense quand même on ne se
rasant pas puisqu'il est barbu à la
présidentielle à gauche jean luc
mélenchon candidat déclaré mais aussi
yannick jadot d'une certaine façon
qu'ils essayent d'enjamber la primaire
d'europe écologie les verts en disant
qu'il faudrait faire une candidature
unique à gauche et puis anne hidalgo qui
ne pensent pas qu'à la mairie de paris
quand elle met des petits bacs pour
végétaliser les rues de paris et qui
pense bien sûr au pays
et pourquoi pas une présidente en 2022
après tout ça fait beaucoup de
prétendants emmanuel macron lui va sans
doute se représenter même si son bilan
risque d'être impacté énormément par
cette gestion calamiteuse de la crise
sanitaire
on se rappelle bien sûr des mensonges
sur les masques on se rappelle des
fiascos sur les tests on se rappelle là
maintenant on les voit les vaccins qui
ne sont pas là les excuses de jean
michel blanquer air sur les ent qui
plante le jour où l'école est fermée
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
fiasco beaucoup de flops
néanmoins pour le moment tout reste
ouvert
la présidentielle c'est dans un an mais
ça commence à occuper beaucoup les
esprits et peut-être avec chance ça va
ça c'est le co vide et on va commencer à
parler d'autre chose
merci on aimerait bien avec six poulains
merci à vous d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
dans le reste de l'actualité jérôme
rodriguez relais ch relaxé par le
tribunal judiciaire de paris il était
jugé pour injures publiques
les précisions de notre reporter bassin
chebbi jérôme rodriguez ali dehors des
gilet jaune relaxé par la justice et
l'état et le syndicat synergie officiers
déboutés de leur demande
suite à ces échanges de tweets entre le
gilet jaune et le syndicat de police où
jérôme rodriguez qualifié la police
nationale de nazis le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin avait réagi
et porté plainte contre le gilet jaune
pour défendre l'honneur des policiers
c'est qu'il avait déclaré le 24 janvier
dernier monsieur rodriguez passer devant
le tribunal à la barre il avait assumé
son tweet et avait déclaré si tu mettras
limiers à son avocat que ses propos
visaient l'institution et non pas des
policiers en particulier l état ainsi
que le syndicat de police avait demandé
à la justice un euro symbolique pour
dommages et intérêts et que jérôme
rodriguez puisse prendre mentir t des
frais de justice alors que m halimi
l'avocat de jérôme rodriguez avait
demandé la relaxe le tribunal a statué
et a prononcé la relaxe du gilet jaune
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur la situation sanitaire
au brésil notamment elle continue de se
dégrader plus de 3000 personnes décèdent
quotidiennement du virus bien plus que
durant le pic de la première vague et
puis nous parlerons d'air france
durement touché par la pandémie
l'état vole à son secours et obtient une
nette de 4 milliards d'euros mais avec
une contrepartie
[Musique]
la gauche aujourd'hui et surtout faible
parce qu'elle a déçu parce qu'elle n'a
pas répondu aux attentes et aux espoirs
qui étaient placés en elle pour vous
c'est quoi finalement
l'enjeu principal les législatives où la
présidentielle nous souhaitons parler
avant tout à toutes celles et ceux qui
n'y croient plus qu'ils s'abstiennent
aujourd'hui voyez il ya énormément de
français aujourd'hui qu'ils ne veulent
plus aller voter puisque vous parlez de
ce nouveau souffle à gauche
cela s'inscrit dans leurs seins dans un
rassemblement on a du mal à comprendre
l'idée d'une candidature communiste je
ne souhaite pas que dès maintenant au
new deal et bien vous n'avez pas le
droit de présenter votre candidature de
quel droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire
ça laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français souhaitent
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous savez
comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sort du côté il est
clair que tout le monde attend sable
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
nous sommes une équipe
[Musique]
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez en espagne
après le week-end de pâques le pays
craint l'arrivée d'une quatrième vague
même si le déplacement entre régions
sont prohibés la mobilité a très
fortement augmenté les interactions
sociales se sont multipliées les six
ingla vous êtes notre correspondante à
barcelone certaines destinations ont été
complètement prise d'assaut tout à fait
dans les stations balnéaires de
catalogne l'affluence était comparable à
celle d'un été avant pandémie les
températures étaient clémentes la météo
radieuse ce qui a tiré les catalans car
il faut rappeler qu'en espagne le
confinement et par région il est
interdit de se déplacer de l'une à
l'autre sauf motif impérieux
mais à l'intérieur la mobilité et sans
restriction certains restaurateurs et
hôteliers ont même indiqué qu'il
s'agissait de l'un des meilleurs
week-end de pâques de ces dernières
années il régnait donc un air de retour
à la vie d'avant mais la réalité
pourrait rapidement rattrapé le pays le
gouvernement craint l'arrivée d'une
nouvelle vague
la vaccination ne suffirait pas à
freiner les chiffres qui repartent déjà
à la hausse
actuellement il ya plus de 12% de la
population vaccinée
le ministère de la santé veut se montrer
rassurant il a indiqué qu un jour de
plus passé est un jour de plus avec plus
de personnes vaccinées alors les régions
prévoit peut-être de durcir les
restrictions dès cette semaine la
catalogne envisage un confinement
périmétrique
mais elle attend d'analyser l'évolution
de la pandémie pour ne pas prendre de
mesures à chaud en tout cas le mois
d'avril sera décisif le premier ministre
pedro sanchez a déjà indiqué que la date
de fin de l'état d'urgence est prévue au
9 mai et l'italienne nouveau classé en
zone rouge s'adapte pour vacciner le
plus de 80 ans
la ville de venise a transformé des
célèbres base aurait tôt des bateaux bus
en centre de vaccination les personnes
âgées de la petite île de sant erasmo
dans la lagune de venise
ont pu recevoir une dose ameil a semblé
se faire vacciner aborde un vaporetto et
admirer la lagune de venise est
désormais possible
l'un de ces bateaux a été transformée en
centre de vaccination flottant pour
permettre aux résidents des îles sans
terrassement et vigneault les de
recevoir leur première injection
j'adore ce matin nous sommes à 100
terrasse moss pour célébrer le lundi de
pâques le jour suivant la résurrection
nos personnes âgées de plus de 80 ans
ils vont sur cette île qui vont se faire
vacciner selon un mode très particulier
nous sommes sur un vaporetto équipés à
cet effet pour pouvoir vacciner les
personnes âgées
ce sont les services de santé de la
région vénétie qui ne laisse personne de
côté
nous sommes ici ce matin pour démontrer
que les services de santé sont un bien
commun et nous les apportons là où ils
sont nécessaires
les deux il ne dispose pas de centres de
vaccination et les déplacements peuvent
être compliqué pour les personnes âgées
c'est pourquoi la municipalité offre
cette possibilité aux habitants très
convaincu par cette initiative un coin
isolé est aménagé à bord du bateau les
autres patients attendent leur tour sur
la rive
cette initiative est géniale qui arrive
ou vaccine si vous avez pris un rendez
vous j'ai été le premier à en avoir un
et là je me sens plutôt bien
selon les rapports des autorités locales
ce dimanche le vaporetto à transporter
200 doses de vaccin de nombreux sites
publics sont également utilisés pour
mener à bien la campagne de vaccination
ailleurs en italie avec de nombreuses
régions classées en rouge le pays a
maintenues ces restrictions pour le
week-end de pâques et aucune procession
n'a eu lieu
les restrictions mises en place le 15
mars dernier ont même été prolongée
jusqu'au 30 avril
on est l'italie toujours où le vaccin
est devenu obligatoire pour tous les
personnels soignants depuis le 31 mars
le gouvernement impose la vaccination
aux médecins infirmiers et pharmaciens
cette obligation s'impose jusqu'au 31
décembre prochain
si cette règle n'est pas respectée des
sanctions sont prévues allant jusqu'à la
suspension d'exercer pour umberto
giovannini médecin chirurgien c'est une
bonne initiative mais il y a trop de
retard dans la campagne vaccinale
italienne il ya eu pas mal dé quoi
qu'ils font qui est encore aujourd'hui
on a des millions des vaccinés retard
par rapport au planning prévu par un par
l'état et dont le personnel soignant
aussi jeudi il ya un moment c'était le
médecin de famille qu'ils ont crié au
scandale du fait qu'ils avaient vacciner
que les gens l'hôpital et pas que le
personnel soignant
on a eu aussi vacciner les
administratifs alors que les médecins du
terrain n'était pas vaccinée donc vous
voyez ces essais sur qui il n'a pas eu
une véritable stratégie et ça aussi je
pense qu'il vient d'un côté renée
l'effet que les corps médical il a
commencé à se dire on peut détacher de
cette campagne massive maximale on n'a
pas été les premiers en première ligne
mais moi qui fut directeur salutaire de
ma clinique qui l'avaient proposé les
transats pour vacciner mais c'était
impossible c'était tout gérer dalle
public et tous gérés par l'administratif
la direction présents le brésil ou la
situation sanitaire continue de se
dégrader 3000 morts quotidiens en
moyenne la semaine dernière un très
lourd bilan triple h le pays juste
derrière
états unis en nombre de cas et de décès
liés au co vide
pas de quoi pour autant faire bouger la
politique de jaillir ball sonar où la
population est excédée grâce à ya des
banderoles et des casseroles vides levés
en signe de protestation ce lundi la
population des dix plus grandes favelas
ce brésilienne est descendue dans les
rues de sao paulo pour exprimer son
ras-le-bol face à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
l'aide d'urgence de vannes d'euros
suffit à acheter une bouteille de gaz
domestique 5 kg de riz et un kilo de
haricots une famille ne peut pas
survivre un mois avec cette aide
c'est une fronde que le brésil un pays
riche avec tant d'opportunités laisse sa
population souffrir de la faim à peine
de quoi vivre quelques jours pour ses
nombreuses familles venues récupérer un
panier alimentaire 150 reais contre les
six ans ou moins de 90 euros qui avait
été attribué par le gouvernement l'an
dernier ed qui a été supprimés au mois
de décembre des décisions
gouvernementales
incomprise par la population fortement
impacté économiquement par la crise
sanitaire
il y a beaucoup de morts de chômage et
tout cela se passe à cause de la
pandémie dans le monde alors que le
président brésilien reste sur sa ligne
en prônant le retour à la vie normale et
la propagation du virus comme moyen
d'atteindre d'immunité collective
les gouverneurs tente de l'enrayer en
confinant localement mais le variant p1
rend impossible un quelconque retour à
la normale une situation qui contribua
femmes et les brésiliens les plus
nécessiteux surtout dans les favelas ce
cela me rend triste j'ai peur que mes
filles et fin l'une d'entre elles a
encore moins de 18 ans j'ai tellement
peur de ne pas avoir assez pour acheter
des choses pour la maison il ya aussi ma
petite fille et je me dis vont elles
avoir faim avec des bilans quotidiens
qui s'élèvent régulièrement à 3000 morts
le brésil est le pays le plus endeuillé
au monde par le coronavirus derrière les
etats-unis en nombre total de cas et de
décès les chiffres ont triplé depuis le
pic atteint entre juin et août 2020 mais
ne font toujours pas d'acier bol sonar
ou qui a vu se succéder pas moins de
quatre ministres de la santé depuis le
début de la pandémie et pour en parler
nous sommes avec daniela be
c'est un conseil du consulat de france à
sao paulo bonsoir daniel allyn merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
2 b le président part dans le brésil qui
affiche un bilan quasi pire que la
première vague comment vous l'expliquez
et le dire c'est pas quasi pire c'est
effectivement pire parce que si on
regarde les chiffres qu'on a quand il ya
eu la première vague en avril mais on a
dépassé ce qu'on avait en avril mais
c'est un peu la même chose de ce qui
s'est passé en europe avec la deuxième
vague annonce qui est regrettable au
brésil c'est que comme on est un peu en
retard par rapport à l'europe
c'est vraiment dommage qu'ici on n'est
pas fait attention à cette deuxième
vague qui allait survenir en novembre
les cas étaient tombés énormément et
malheureusement ça a repris de plus
belle alors il ya plusieurs facteurs
pour cela un des facteurs fait qu'on a
actuellement dans la ville de sao paulo
deux tiers des patients pour la variante
appelé p1 de manas ours une variante qui
est beaucoup plus transmissible et
peut-être beaucoup plus létal
ça c'est le premier détail le deuxième
détail c'est que malheureusement au
brésil qui est un pays quand même assez
pauvre dans son ensemble cette équation
entre rester à la maison et travailler
elle est devenue très compliquée les
subventions du gouvernement pour ceux
qui travaillent ou qui ont perdu leur
travail ou qui ne sont même pas
enregistré comme travailleur c'est ça a
été l'année dernière plus ou moins de 90
euros par mois pendant trois mois
c'est largement insuffisant maintenant
parle à nouveau d'une aide de 60 euros
sur trois mois ce qui est aussi
largement insuffisant donc les
brésiliens se trouve face à un double
problème la pandémie qui grâce et qui
effectivement est devenue grave on a
pratiquement dans tout le brésil
90 % d'occupation dans les unités de
soins intensifs
ce qui surchargent terriblement les
hôpitaux et en même temps le peuple qui
a besoin de manger kids on doit
travailler
donc c'est un double problème êtes très
difficile à régler mais actuellement
ce qui concerne la pandémie on est
effectivement sur un niveau très grave
pire ce que ce qu'on avait en mars avril
mai de l'année dernière quand il ya eu
la première ronde et on a une grosse
difficulté à régler cette
transmissibilité
alors il ya eu des espèces de look down
mais c'est pas du tout les log dingue
qu'on observe en europe qui sont
beaucoup plus réduit
le clae goreux issil isolement social
est exigée mais il est disons beaucoup
plus lâches
donc finalement vous avez les
agglomérations qui se font de toute
façon sur le transport public avec les
gens qui sont obligés de travailler dans
les services essentiels
vous avez ensuite les cette existence
des favelas ce où on est à cinq ou six
dans une pièce donc malheureusement ça
favorise ça favorise énormément la
transmission du virus donc au brésil
et c'est un peu c'est un peu la
situation pour tout le brésil s'est pas
seulement la ville de são paulo là où
j'exerce tout le brésil est actuellement
sur une situation très très dangereuse
et c'est vraiment très sérieux alors
manifestement vous n'êtes pas aider un
parole le gouvernement on connaît la
forme de déni qui a toujours exercé
jaillir un bol sonar haut
les populations s'en exaspère commence à
s'en agacer justement de cette politique
sanitaire ou cette non politique même
sanitaire du président brésilien
oui ce qui commence à y avoir c'est une
certaine indignation
avec cette espèce de new delhi
effectivement du point de vue politique
les opinions un peu changé on a
maintenant la population qui est
vraiment un peu on peut dire un peu plus
irrité et indigné avec ce qui se passe
du point de vue de la pandémie parce que
les gens commencent à se rendre compte
qu'effectivement la situation est très
sérieuse et le président lui il insiste
énormément sur 7 sur cette idée de
reprendre le travail pour que les gens
puissent manger normalement dans un
certain sens il a un peu raison mais
malheureusement en milieu de la pandémie
si on fait pas attention on va vraiment
avoir des problèmes donc son appui
politique commence à diminuer
on va voir un peu comment se passe le
restant on commence à vacciner mais sur
un rythme assez lent vu la taille du
pays dans la ville de sao paulo on a
déjà fait pratiquement 2 millions de
vaccins en tout il ya cinq cent mille
personnes
mais malheureusement vu la taille du
pays on et 210 millions d'habitants il
ya eu 20 millions de vaccins utilisés
mais c'est vraiment pas assez vu la
taille du pays avant on puisse endiguer
la la pandémie avec les vaccins sarah
met un certain temps l'estimatif c'est
pour nora vacciner tout le monde ici
seulement à la fin de l'année ce qui
préoccupe énormément
le brésil qui a prouvé en urgence john
seine mais une seule dose qu'elle est
justement la situation pour bien qu'on
comprenne chez vous sur le plan des
vaccins vous en avez combien disponible
aujourd'hui on est actuellement deux
vaccins disponibles le vaccin corona
vague qui est un vaccin fait parler
chinois airs fabriquée ou importée mais
partiellement fabriquée avec les
composants primaires chinois il ya 46
millions de doses qui vont être
jusqu'en mai pour tout le brésil il est
fabriqué dans l'état de sao paulo est
ensuite avéré au vaccin
astrazeneca anglais qui est également
distribuée dans tout le brésil vous avez
actuellement on a actuellement pu
distribuer jusqu'à maintenant 20
millions de vaccins ce qui représente
quand même un petit pourcentage vu la
population
on a deux vaccins actuellement on n'a
pas encore autorisé le vaccin russe le
spoutnik
on n'a pas autorisé le vaccin janssen
dont malheureusement on en est à ces
deux vaccins et le vaccin files ère
moderne à mon on l'aura peut-être vers
août septembre ce qui va
considérablement retardé le disons la
diminution de l'épidémie et ce qui
préoccupe tout le monde parce que le
brésil fini par fonctionner comme un
réservoir de virus ce qui peut être
dangereux pour tout le monde surtout
avec cette nouvelle variante et cette
variante p1 de manaus il y à aussi pour
expliquer la situation compliquée au
brésil
la question des des variants est ce
qu'on en sait plus sur les variants
aujourd'hui au brésil combien sont ils
alors il ya plus ou moins trois ou
quatre variants qui sont apparus ce qui
préoccupe énormément ce sont ces c'est
la variante p1 manar ours comme je vous
disais deux tiers des cas à sceaux où
l'eau sont des cas de cette variante p1
il ya un gros problème est que cette
variante ps et qu'elle même ceux qui ont
eu le qu'ovide l'année dernière n'ont
pas de protection pour cette nouvelle
variante donc ça fait un double problème
d'abord toute la population redevient
susceptible avec un virus qui est plus
transmises qui se transmet plus
facilement et qui est hôte est beaucoup
plus létal
merci daniel habib médecin conseil du
consulat de france à sao paulo d'avoir
été avec nous en direct pour nous
expliquer donc la situation très
compliquée au brésil merci à vous
l'hexagone va pouvoir allonger de 4
milliards d'euros les aides accordées
air france durement frappé par la crise
sanitaire la commission européenne vient
de donner son feu vert au plan de
sauvegarde la compagnie aérienne une
validation obtenu en échange de quelques
sacrifices
hélas medjahed la commission européenne
autorise la france à convertir un prêt
de 3 milliards d'euros en fonds propres
paris peut également monter au capital
en injectant jusqu'à un milliard d'euros
une recapitalisation d'air france à
hauteur d'un peu moins de 30 % faisant
de l'état
le premier actionnaire de la compagnie
aérienne selon bruno le maire le
ministre français de l'économie
bruxelles a donc approuvé le projet de
l'état français mais a aussi imposé ses
conditions
en contrepartie air france devra céder
18 créneaux de vol à d'autres compagnies
aériennes d'orly ce qui représente
environ 4% de ses créneaux sur cet
aéroport parisien
la montée au capital c'est quelque chose
d'indispensable
on ne pouvait pas continuer sur cette
trajectoire là ça va dans le sens de ce
qu'on demandait ce n'est pas de l'argent
injecté ce sont des prêts le scandale
c'est d'avoir cédé face à la commission
céder des créneaux c'est mettre en
difficulté l'entreprise même si c'est
moins que les 24 créneau prévu
initialement
l'aéroport d'orly est un petit aéroport
ce n'est pas à munich ou francfort
qu'est ce qu'on va faire des salariés
qui travaillaient sur l'activité qu'on
va céder 8500 emplois doivent être
supprimés d'ici 2022 au sein d'air
france et de sa filiale régionale
hop un plan de transformation de la
compagnie aérienne pour surmonter selon
la direction
la crise économique et l'effondrement du
trafic passager lié à la pandémie de
coronavirus au delà d'air france c'est
tout le groupe air france klm qui est à
la peine
l'entreprise franco néerlandaise prévoit
une perte d'exploitation d'un milliard
trois cents millions d'euros au premier
trimestre 2010 21
le groupe qui a déjà été très fortement
touchées l'an dernier par la crise du
coc vie 19
air france klm a perdu 7 milliards
d'euros en 2020 et vu son chiffre
d'affaires s'effondrer de 59% par
rapport à 2019
une déroute à l'image de l'ensemble du
secteur aérien mondial
et pour en parler nous sommes avec henri
sterdyniak économiste nom des
économistes atterrés bonsoir henri
sterdyniak merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france la récup a été
recapitalisé actions d'air france par
l'état français
c'est une bonne nouvelle a aujourd'hui
pour pour la compagnie oui bien sûr
c'est une bonne touche dont la compagnie
à l'entreprise a perdu beaucoup d'argent
en 2020 elle risque d'en perdre encore
en 2000 le gratia donc elle a besoin à
la fois de près ce qu'ils ont été
accordés en 2000 chars des prêts
garantis par l'état et elle a besoin de
fonds prendre pedro que l'arbre lui
donne à milhas de son propre et 3
milliards d'obligations convertibles
donc ça lui donne une certaine marge
pour passer l'année 2021
l'état qui redevient ans parce qu'on se
rappelle qu'il était déjà dès 1945 sauf
erreur de ma part le premier actionnaire
de la compagnie en quelque sorte c'est
un retour à la case départ
oui c'est toujours avec un départ d'une
situation qui est quand même très
difficile après la guerre air france
était une entreprise en plein essor est
resté longtemps notre prise phare pour
l'économie française
là on est dans une situation beaucoup
plus difficile c'est une autre prise en
difficulté à la fois en raison de la
pandémie en raison de la concurrence
d'un certain nombre de compagnies soit
low cost soit aidée massivement par les
pays du golfe et par ailleurs c'est une
entreprise qui est confrontée aux
problèmes posés par la transition
écologique est donc là l'état intervient
comme un pompier pour essayer de
préserver ce qui peut l'être dans cette
entreprise
justement vous parlez de la transition
écologique on entend alors ce sont
peut-être des micros voit la déclaration
mais quand même il ya une tendance de
fond à une mère écologiste celle de
poitiers nous dire que voilà le rêve ne
doit plus être celui de l'aviation est
ce qu'il y ait encore un si bel avenir
qu'avant pour justement l'aviation et
des compagnies aériennes aea france
notamment son départ si bel avenir vous
savez déjà que hope interdire les
liaisons qui peuvent être faites par la
route par le chemin de fer
si ça prend moins de 2h30 déjà c'est une
partie du marché qui disparaît il ya les
problèmes du tourisme qui risque d'être
durablement affectés par la pandémie est
bien le fait que grosso modo entre le
prix de des transports va augmenter et
elle le fait que jusqu'à présent n'a pas
encore d'actions propres donc on demande
à la france de réduire de façon très
importante ses émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dans les années à venir
là aussi ça va peser sur le profit des
entreprises et donc ce sont des france
comme beaucoup d'entreprises de
transport est une des entreprises qui
risque d'être le plus frappé par la
transition écologique et donc l'état
intervienne pour soutenir une entreprise
qui va devoir d'un côté se transformer
et de l'autre sans doute diminuer sa
voilure et donc c'est vraiment un
sauvetage nécessaire ninacs diminuer sa
voilure ça ça veut dire quoi
parce que cette arrivée d'argent
n'empêche pas 8500 poids d'être
supprimés chez air france ça veut dire
qu'il faudra encore supprimé voire
licenciés dans la compagnie nationale
ça veut dire que la transition
écologique suppose un certain nombre
d'évolutions structurels dans l'économie
française économie européenne l'économie
mondiale sans doute il va falloir à
l'avenir à avoir moins de transport
moins de tourisme est donc utile grande
question c'est de reconvertir les
personnels de ces entreprises et n'ont
pas forcément de dire à sauver coûte que
coûte les emplois donc la question qui
est posée pour air france comme bout un
certain nombre d'entreprises
c'est celui de reconvertir une partie du
personnel dans d'autres activités qui
sont plus compatible avec l'économie
relativement simple économie sommes dont
nous aurons besoin dans les années à
venir
sauf miracle sauf si effectivement on
trouve l'argent le l'avion propre la
halle avions qui volent sans émettre de
gaz à effet de serre naturellement il va
falloir
réduire les activités qui sont
relativement prudentes alors dernière
question c'est que ça s'est pas fait
sans contrepartie la perte des femmes 18
slota orly qui représente 4% des
créneaux de la compagnie est ce qu'ils
vont avoir un impact important
comme vous l'avez dit ce n'est que
quatre courses hors d'eux écrit nos deux
défenseurs lee donc c'est pas tragique
compte tenu du fait que grosso modo
l'activity d'air france doit quand même
un peu ralentir d'autre part air france
a pu voir choisir les créneaux qu'elle
vend donc on peut penser qu'elle va
choisir les créneaux les moins
intéressants d'autre part air france et
l'état français ont obtenu le droit de
ne pas les vendre à des entreprises qui
respectent pas des normes sociales et
environnementales donc ça permet
d'écarter ryanair donc l'entreprise s'en
sort relativement bien
beaucoup d'entreprises en france qui
souffrent beaucoup en 2021 qui vont
avoir besoin de fonds propres
hélas l'état intervient quand même
massivement pour aider à france
il faut souhaiter qu'ils interviennent
aussi pour aider d'autres entreprises
moins emblématiques mais qui ont des
problèmes similaires à ceux d'air france
en particulier parmi les entreprises de
taille intermédiaire et le petit domaine
entreprises merci henri sterdyniak
économiquement des économistes atterrés
merci d'avoir été avec nous et c'est la
fin de cette émission prochain point
complet sur l'actualité dans quelques
minutes
[Musique]
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
était arrivé au bout de ce qu'il pouvait
supporter il ya énormément de problèmes
en france comment se fait-il qu'on est
les impôts les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés c'est impossible